you may have heard that YouTube
announced YouTube TV last week which is
a paid subscription for 35 bucks a month
you can get six profiles one account and
access to over 40 traditional broadcast
and basic cable channels now this is
really cool here's why this service and
others like it such as sling and DirecTV
now are changing the way that you
consume TV across the board or year
companies have tried to figure out a way
where people can consume all of their
media from one app at one place and now
here at this moment in history were
finally at a place where that's going to
become a real thing and over the next
five years you could be watching YouTube
videos right alongside your favorite
shows right alongside your favorite
movies and all of those things are going
to be available in the same place we're
finally here at the production office
for lifeline within this building there
are dozens of people right now all
working really hard because we are
shooting in a week to prepare our
locations costume sets so and so forth
paperwork cameras and it's really really
fun and I believe today we have one of
our actresses here Sydney Park who is
now undergoing some butterfly night
training for her character let's take a
peek inside I'll show you around
you follow me upstairs where we do most
of our work last couple days we've been
meeting here going through the script
back and forth and back and forth I feel
like I've got this memorized trucks back
at this point give these sick bases
hello
for when you get sleepy but they just
get so boring you have to go to bed it's
definitely the biggest project we've
ever done but that doesn't mean we have
to lose everything we've learned in
shooting YouTube videos for the shoot
we'll be using a lot of cool red cameras
they're nice and big but we want to
utilize the more modern stuff here B&H
hooked us up by sending along the sony
a7s - and one of the Atomos flames here
is not only does the a savanna to having
brandable low-light capabilities and you
can shoot in moonlight basically with
this thing what the add most Shogun
flames provide though this thing work
towards in 10 bit 4k the challenge here
is Niko myself really liked gimbals we
also really liked hoverboard that's
something we really want to bring to
this production because it's a very very
handy way to get smooth shop and also
utilizes all this new technology that's
available to us these days Adrien
doesn't know how to ride hoverboard he's
very very skeptical that this rig is
going to work over the next week or so
before we shoot it's my job to convince
them that it's totally okay to ride
around on a hoverboard as long as you're
using a camera at the same time the
problem is these services haven't quite
figured out how to get every channel
that you can get with basic cable and
that's probably just a matter of numbers
and costs and I think over time the more
people that buy these services and more
and more channels will trickle in the
great thing for us and for people like
you that like watching YouTube content
you're going to be able to watch us
alongside the other channels and movies
that you already like to watch via TV
you just won't have to leave and go to a
YouTube app you just watched all from
the same spot it will also allow for
people that are responsible for buying
shows to look at the correlations and
the similarities between content there
might be an executive producer out there
somewhere who sees corridor digital
videos alongside sci-fi videos and
you know what there's a real opportunity
to make something really cool here and
those types of opportunities have never
existed before if you're still not
convinced that these types of services
will become prevalent in almost every
household over the next five years
consider your smartphone at one point
your smartphone was a phone an answering
machine a directory a TomTom you have
reached your destination a Mac a compass
a pager a TV an alarm a watch a
flashlight computer camera walkman radio
notepad calendar delivery service ax e
bank gaming console guitar tuner
microphone recorder level remote control
police scanner Walmart and almost every
other store for that matter and even a
fire starter
think about all of those items and how
much it cost to have all of those things
and now you can get them all in one
night place the same thing is happening
now with the way that you watch
television the next step here is
convincing Adrienne that this camera
setup is even worth using on the shoot
yeah so on rush I can't we go sleeping
like once a day we found the entire
shoot is
where did
letting more photos nico of you sleeping
on set will be like a little collage for
those of you out there who don't know
the difference between 8 and 10 bit
here's my 32nd crashed or 8 bit files
and what does that means that you're
limited to 256 values for your light and
color data and all that stuff
10 suddenly that 256 goes into the
thousand you get you get a file that is
much closer to the one that we need for
collaborating in-house cool she's doing
punching and kicking so for those of you
don't know nil-nil Stewart actually
worked with us on Rush and been
coordinating and making sure that all
the stuff are often this is Sydney part
and she's going to be playing Norah in
this series as well might recognize her
from the walking dead
among other things today these guys are
going through barbed line night training
which I don't know much about is all
these workers are about 20 20 minutes
this morning
yep any previous book no no I didn't
know you any is young yes that's court
days I didn't think we'd get this far
and the first simple to where it's like
you don't know it's there but then you
flip it out and you're like ready to go
yeah yeah thank you
yes you know I'm not going to call don't
pull them in on it you don't call me no
no I haven't sir I did it one you've
never done this back home I was just for
you yeah hey you don't know I am here to
wrong play good send me a little Jackson
get an Oscar no where is Samuel Jackson
right now and room in downtown LA my
license open in full